hello everyone and welcome to the
greatest form of game you will ever see
now that is a pretty bold statement and
I've seen a lot of form of games and
this is the one I enjoy the most and
it's not even a fabrication the game was
actually played in tournament play
between two masters but unfortunately
I've I've seen this game in a book but I
haven't been able to find it in the free
database that I'm using who played it so
now hence the hoodie guys here and I
know it may be better if I were to who
this is since there are two hoodie guys
but it's extremely hot here and even one
hoodie is pushing it so without further
ado let's check it out and yeah sorry
for no video yesterday but I've been
very busy preparing everything for the
podcast with Mal that's why I'm trying
to get everything working and in order
now but yeah this is one game I always
wanted to show you guys and the one that
I very joyfully show people when I I I'm
with someone in a company and they enjoy
chess and then they ask me like is there
like a really cool quick game you can
show me and then I show them this and
they are of course very happy and
impressed so I know you guys are super
popular with your friends in the bar in
the library and after showing this
they're just gonna go through the roof
so without further ado let's check it
out so white opened with d4 and the
black replied with Knight to f6 so
everything is you know perfectly normal
and here white goes for the for the odd
night the d2 but it's been played over
450 times in tournament play so it's not
that weird of a move you can use it to
maybe surprise your opponents and here
black replied with E 5 an early pawn
sacrifice that double White's pawn
structure and then and just go Knight g4
to recapture the pawn
so here white grab the pawn and we have
Knight the g4 and here white is thinking
okay I have to doubled pawns on the
e-file I'm not interested in keeping
them I just want to continue development
he played h6 point being that now after
Knight captures you just want to
continue developing night a3 for Bishop
b2 or maybe c4 castles and so on however
white is completely lost here and the
black can win the game on the spot so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the winning idea for black
and figure out if this is the greatest
form of game ever played well I'll give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on completing the best
ever form of game and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's not Queen to h4 a lot of people are
a try Queen to h4 here the problem is
okay you're threatening someone here but
after g3 and Queen H 60s white still
cannot capture but after the knight
develops black no longer has any threats
so not not a not a solution and also if
you were thinking about Knight captures
an f2 that's not going to work because
after King captures Queen h4 check you
can just block all the checks g3 and
after a queen check series we are gonna
play e3 queen characters just Knight f3
and the black has no compensation for
for the sacrifice piece so the point is
after h3 black wins by playing Knight
the e3 and this is a game over now point
is white queen is trapped and there's
nothing you can do about it so you're
definitely losing the Queen and of
course if you don't want to lose the
Queen and the capture denied then its
Queen h4 check g3 and Queen captures and
g3 checkmate
so after h3 and knights the e3 it was in
this position that white resigned the
game as there was nothing more to be
done so there it is four moves I really
do hope you enjoyed it the player with
the white piece is definitely didn't but
I will try to try to figure out which
game this was as I do know that I've
written in some book and it was maybe a
book in miniature or something but the
the game actually happened in tournament
play between chess masters so really
exciting stuff I do also hope your
friends at bar in the library enjoy it
and yeah I mean go go into the world and
impress everyone
so I won a very short game I don't
usually do short games like this but
like I said I make very very busy making
sure everything is properly set up for
the podcast as I've bought a lot of
equipment which I've never actually used
the the cloud lifter the the the new
microphone well there's like uh a lot of
equipment so it took us a while to set
everything up but yeah that's the
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank the Benjamin reaching Bhupinder
ostrich etre Scott Western Joshua GUI
and the Jonathan air for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos serum thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga and whatever else happens in the
chess world so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day